good evening and welcome I'd like to
take this opportunity is the sound
working in the other room okay I'd like
to take this opportunity to again thank
Amy Myers director of the Yale Center
for British art and miR Kosar Nene and
Phyllis Lambert of the Canadian Centre
for architecture for their gracious
partnership and collaboration in jointly
presenting the concurrent James Stirling
exhibitions that are of wide interest in
both the school and the profession in
2007 Peter Eisenman inaugural Charles
Gwathmey professor and practice in our
school embarked on a series of
occasional conversations with important
contributors to contemporary
architectural discourse not only talking
with practicing architects who write
about the history and theory of the
discipline but also with public
intellectuals who look at our world from
the outside
professor Yzerman's inaugural
conversation was with Rafael Moneo one
of Spain's leading architects and Jose
Luis their professor of architecture at
Harvard's Graduate School of Design this
was followed by a conversation with the
author Tom Wolfe an event waggish Lee
referred to by some as Peter and the
wolf
that conversation marked the quarter
century since the publication from
Bauhaus to our house mr. wolf's
excoriating critique of Orthodox
architectural modernism this evening
pardon me following upon Dean Edwards
lecture of last Thursday at the Yale
University Art Gallery and Dean Robert
Maxwell's lecturer earlier this week in
art school professor Eisenman and
Anthony viddler Dean of the Cooper Union
School of Architecture will discuss the
lessons and insights gleaned from Dean
vid was meticulous exploration of the
James Stirling Michael Wilfred archive
at the Canadian Centre for architecture
additional Stirling programming will be
continued next month with two more
lectures on Wednesday November 10th
professor Kurt Forster will speak at the
Yale Center for British art and on
Thursday November 11th professor our
Emmanuel petit
will conclude the series with a lecture
here in Hastings Hall
Anthony Villa received both his Bachelor
of Arts in architecture and Fine Arts
and his diploma in architecture from
Cambridge University he also holds the
PhD in architecture from Delft
University of Technology in the
Netherlands Dean viddler started
Princeton University is instructor
assistant and associate professor and as
William R cannon jr. chair of
architecture a position he held until he
briefly decamped to Ithaca to become
Dean of the College of art and
architecture and planning at Cornell
before going on to UCLA where he was
chief professor and chair of the
department of art history in 2002
professor Villa moved to New York where
he is currently Dean of the Irwin estrin
and School of Architecture at the Cooper
Union Dean viddler is the author of a
number of significant books on
historical and contemporary topics in
architecture including Warped space
published in 2000 by the
might depress his first book Claude
Nikolai Badou architecture and social
reform at the end of the ancien régime
published in 1990 also by the MIT press
received the Alice Davis Hitchcock award
of the Society of architectural
historians a great distinction Dean
viddler is also author of the
exceptional catalog now available for
purchase at local book shops James
Fraser sterling notes from the archive
published by the Yale Press which is the
companion publication to the current
Yale Center for British art exhibition
please join me in welcoming Peter
Eisenman and Anthony Midler to the
podium or to the table for this evenings
conversation
in any case I do want to say I think I'm
the last of the three little pigs could
be eaten by the wolfy
why these are up here today so those of
you to whom my remarks make all what you
will your last opportunity in any case I
reminded that not to go
friends do a performance of Krapp's Last
Tape and it's a 50 minute performance
where this gentle person I assume whose
name is Pratt never specified speaks a
tape recorder and speaks to the tape
recorder at the time and I was thinking
that since none of you probably have
read this book and all of my questions
have to do with what Dean Midler said in
this book we wouldn't have a
conversation like Krapp's Last Tape but
my things are all good conversations are
totally unintelligible to anybody but
the Dukan versus you also realize that
I'm very proud who happened to be fifty
years ago to this very moment my first
student when I began teaching at the
University so I'm very proud of this I
told my students today I hope they
aspire Oh master
under the bridge in any case I'm going
to ask because we can talk freely
hopefully you will enjoy this and if you
don't think you know rewind that they
can find the gun if you want I'm going
to start for those of you who read this
Bible in chapter 6 which deals after the
great period of the lesser engineering
building the Florida College at Oxford
and the Cambridge history faculty
buildings so starts in about 67 or 68 I
think 68 should be the crucial floor
Cambridge history and luster which ended
67
okay got it that vans in 67 68 is a
cataclysmic year especially so in
architecture and I think it had to be
slightly cataclysmic for Jim sterling
because Liam clear that shooting into
his office and you know I think my
career has left in his wake and wake of
devastation
starting with Michael Graves and
numerous others ending with my first
piece you can yeah there's another one
and Leon is a wonderful teacher
architect and actually a friend to both
of us
tell me I think drives to down I would
like to think that what I read was a
downplaying of the influence of career
the studio starting in 68 I would argue
that if we take the the first project
the Siemens project which I think comes
right out of careers this course before
then comes to Sterling but it's not that
the project after Siemens which is which
is Darby this is the city center which
is really Leon's hand and what we need
to do is to say how important was star
be in this process because I think after
68 things change and I for me not
necessarily for the better we're going
to
about that because we've got some
projects at you and I will sneak them
out and within this hour but I'd like to
start with the problematic of Darby
which seems to me to be something of a
what Colin Rowe would call a set-piece
it seems to be a contextual piece it
seems to be again in common rose liturgy
a catcher's mitt and so one is clear but
the other is the ROE influence because
if there weren't those impulses already
within sterling from Roe and of course
Roe was his studio master for his his
thesis at Liverpool and I think trying
to elude Roe was one of Jim's those I as
it was mine and yours what do you think
about that because let's talk about Roe
career sterling sixty-eight Darby
okay Siemens and right Siemens is I
don't have a project up on the screen
but if you remember it it's these great
cylindrical towers office towers with
Sun shields that rotate around the
office towers and you know imagine
computer control so the light side down
but like that you know what what can
Frampton call the kind of a cyber city
in the German and Derby which is
completely the opposite right so these
are cylindrical solid figures marking
down and
lutely direct symmetrical axis and Derby
is the careful weaving of a of a the
Galleria along the edge of a of an
already-existing if that's the already
existing town center of what sterling
does is to weave a gallon ria around the
edge of the town center in order to
create a public space and the whole
thing
Pochiro yes is figure-ground right now
it seems to me well two things one
Siemens is dated both in the archive and
in Korea's own publications before he
then goes on to do cylindrical housing
in Berlin
sterling had already work on individual
mechanized typology Xin Dorman long that
long building which actually refers I
think more directly to Cedric pricing it
does right beyond pre-finish Olivetti
anyway what I'm trying to say is I think
that there were a whole range of
interests and ways of solving problems
in sterling before young fear emerges in
Sterling's office with surprising talent
for drawing
I think if Siemens is creative and Derby
is not if Derby is clear then Siemens is
problem or sterling and I think that
Derby itself is an anomaly in Sterling's
work and I'm perfectly willing to agree
that there's something very
fundamentally crea row like in in Darby
the question is first of all because I
think the other contextual buildings
that come after which we're going to be
speaking about have nothing to do with
Darby and they are completely different
in their ways of contextualization
in contextualization but the way they
insert their programmatic elements into
the city but there is a shift I would
argue in the in the discourse which is
never recaptured for me but I think that
shift is not just Krieger I think shift
is fundamental in the Olin shift we
actually ran individual building no but
this [ __ ] mob occurs in 68 through
Ross's architecture the city manager is
complexin all of the things that's been
building since the mid sixties
crystallizes itself in 68 I would argue
that first of all we can't have all
canonical buildings so whatever we are
going to be done we're talking about a
great architect one of the four or five
great architects of the last half of the
20th century so any critique we are
going to indulge in here but it's within
the context of a grid at some point in
the conversation I want you to define
canonical form okay read me out
let's go to row man to rotor which is
another of Jim's pieces long after Liana
John which you say is not collage and I
want to know why
romantic Dorota is for Jim seems to be
taking set pieces to produce with his
set pieces and he falls some Cola as she
calls them contextualism because of lots
of things so it seemed to me and Roman
to wrote it is one of the places where
Jim and Colin come closest to the being
together and yet you make a point in
your text to say in fact that this is
not what's on mine well you've compared
Colin's contribution to roaming ferrata
right and and sterling and rocky right
okay so at 3 we in the exhibition we
have the original drawing before
sterling and for rossi roaming
throughout the newly flat and collins is
a really installation of a total city
fabric with thicker ground within it
Stirling's is the insertion of
individual built projects in the field
and outside and inside of alpha city
itself and Ross's is the construction of
a huge mega institutional building and I
think those three those three are
fundamentally different in their
approaches for the city well let's ask
the question even
you call one of your chapters we base
which is elements individual discrete
elements of assemble together in a city
fabric cut out in a bigger ground
way in order to the edge of pieces but
essentially most of them take on object
like I mean to mention one it is really
a set piece it's a it moves from the
three museum project which elements
inserted into a city driver to a
building which is a small city in itself
now let's go back for me the second
interesting trying I want to get to that
the this is Java Central cologne
düsseldorf are the next three just so
called for me that another architect you
mentioned Rossi and of course at some
point we have to the Square will see and
it's early but in some way but the third
architect that needs to be squared in
this circle is owners and it seems to me
if I went back to the siemens project I
would say the siemens project comes out
of the kind of preparatory neoclassical
Humber's is working on so that careers
movement from although we never worked
the fishing monomers he moves from
Germany where his brother was working
with hunger and sucked up to sterling
and so the Siemens thing could quite
naturally come out of a discourse of
something that was happening in Germany
I would argue I would agree ok now it
seems to me then if we go to cologne
düsseldorf in Stuttgart which are poses
to the discourse of German which is
posed to the German typical yeah but but
they're very close to some of the the
urban projects that Congress was working
ok so and I did not mention it in the
book and it will be in the second
edition ok because I think there's a
very strong influence of Hungary in
those three yeah I was terrible no I
wasn't I mean I'm serious
you know I thought about it after the
fact the proofs were in and you know
when you go through the history of the
period and you look at owners museum
project yes I think there's a there's a
fundamental influence of fungus and
probably more hunger as than I don't
think queer broad numbers I think
actually une des was when I was at
Cornell he was a corny starting in
Cornell in 73 later ok what ran I have
REM ceases project
the CSIs project that the AAA handed in
in the spring of 72
but ramen goes to Ithaca on Harkness in
his full 72 last for six months and then
arrived at the Institute somewhere in
the spring of 73 the talent flag is look
joins him in the summer of 70 ready and
shares an office with him so we we date
REMS voyage to Ithaca after he leads the
a 72 to be with Matthias who comes in
the fall of 72 or the spring okay
Leone arrives in Ithaca and after rent
is left in the spring of 74 and leaves
very quickly very quickly three days or
four days realizes that this is a
problem so the the hungers influence and
I think is important on though in those
three months yes
another influencer that you talk about a
great deal is the the different use of
the promenade which Stirling brings back
as it were from modernist preoccupations
but in an entirely different figural
form very different than Porvoo in these
projects and I want to know if you want
to comment on now we've done no longers
the the question of the architecture
promenade it's very nice because what's
very interesting because in his notebook
in the fifties when he visits Paris and
he says I was disappointed with the
Corps right right because he'd seen them
in the books Carlin had you know gone
over and over and over with them but
when he actually saw these dirty sort of
bill maintained stained and quite poor
looking little buildings he was
disappointed except for the Salvation
Army building wiki said this is the
toughest urban building I've seen why he
thought it was urban was that it was not
just a slab but it was also a slab
entered in a very special way
up the steps into a little square
pavilion you turn right in the square
pavilion that has an l-shaped turn you
across a bridge into a cylinder your
turn by the cylinder and then into the
slab so you don't go to the slab and
then run right through it you're
actually parallel for the slab all the
way in a promenade right and that is
exactly what he does at initial door
there's a void and a little bit of yeah
no no but this this diagram is precisely
yeah
the square there was a wiggle thing the
circle yup dia disassembles
the entry sequence to the Salvation Army
building track changes the scale inverts
the cylinder into a into a boy and then
as the the first time the first time
that is we're talking about yeah here's
the first it appears in yeah first yes
but this'll door first and then it's
going to reappear and in a very poetic
gesture because it appears on all the
flight material from the invitation
cards to the the changing money slip to
the Pan Am ticket through to the Nepal
Airlines ticket he is designing
Dusseldorf with Corbusier Salvation Army
on his way to Canada right absolutely
but the disel Dorf project and then we
have to ask the question of this rotunda
space because the rotunda space that she
will design
is the sound but in all of Sterlings
absolutely and if you look at the
drawing position he has these beautiful
little red arrows which trace the
circulation around that for that right
so what we have to understand is while
we are looking at a play on the office
Museum in terms of the sort of the drum
in the center and without the without
the cat right it's voided and that's
that so I think there's also a death the
Schinkel of Lazarus to the Corbusier but
there's a miss reading of the shingle
good not for good or bad just it is miss
reading of Cobra yet now now we got to
get to rice because I'm a little
perplexed because when I look at the
pictures in here that you used to
illustrate the I think it's just heavy
Taurani as a matter of fact I'm trying
to find the images for the stone
influences are very much more in the
Sackler galleries and we'll get to that
I'm thinking of rice in particular in
that building where there is a modernist
injured a complete nostalgic frame
that's a well it's an ironic pastiche of
the architecture one thing - ramicus the
the oculus is off-center the oculus is
off-center the moldings and the dentals
are computed wrongly placed and leave it
and the like
I think I think any building could be a
bad build
I'm talking about right because we were
starting to get into where I think
something goes lightly all in the not
ironic pastiche let's say and I think it
first goes off it rice I'm not convinced
of rice but you had a but then we go
well it's not let's go back to that
because I think there's a there's a
remember Charlie Gwathmey and his
building at Princeton could that be a
bad building I didn't think it was the
modernist insertions it would play
openly overtly
I mean in other words the exterior skin
was taken away and revealed the
modernist injuries so I play was a shell
with this interior when you look at rice
only see is the shell yeah no you see
the conical yes skylights pushing
through like something out of a tea
wells or most houses or I mean I have to
say again I think it's a I think it's
elegant solution to a very difficult
problem is what you do in that kind of
campus where you're actually mandated
according to quote-unquote
style secondly but I don't necessarily I
think there are L ite versions of one's
building
given the kind of productivity that any
architect type of course I mean but
we've already put on the plus-side
Cambridge Oxford Leicester cologne
düsseldorf stood guard mousing and plus
Preston and common so far so far whereas
your Dow is up in the master
maybe sort of falling a little bit and
then Dow is up he's doing well we it's
the next five buildings in some sort of
order that we need to talk about Sackler
Cornell mission shop central latina okay
and I I know Tony viddler well I think
and but I've heard reports of even
beyond this book of your love for latina
the bibliothèque de France Sackler
Cornell and I I've been correct the
record
rumors of rumors and in all political
campaign rumors gained traction but I
think I would say that I do like the
library of latina
that I am attracted and particularly
interested in the Cornell assemblage and
I think that the Sackler lost its raison
d'etre when it lost its bridge here but
yeah I think it lost its raison d'etre
when things imagined have to go up the
stairs and it has to come down it's a
very different promenade you know that's
not my concern
okay I mean that wouldn't bother me or
who you know like if you don't like the
stripe I don't like the stripes I don't
like them on business out Centrum
I think the stripes when he starts to
candy-coat the projects they're not
volumetric in for me
used to be it's a different kind of
volumetric it's a different I think what
I've got to get to is the statement in
the book that it's too bad he didn't win
the big well only because I have to work
in the one that did win no no no but I
am talking about the one that did win
I'm talking about the one that I like a
lot which is the REM koolhaas or the
bran cool Alfred yes well you don't but
you don't mention that that it would
have been preferable it's cool not what
I mean
for me there's what we needed to get
clear for everybody is because I thought
up until I read this about
I I really don't like these biblioteca
de France and I need you to tell me what
about this sort of chocolate cream roll
for a building what are those big nestle
role I don't get it and detective
problems and just are two of his most
famous project and for me it's a
canonical bill is well I don't believe
Jim sterling I agree with you okay no
but the way it comes up in the book it's
sort of a lost leader well it's a
competition entry it's not a it's not a
finished building I think I think the
idea that he had of a library city as
opposed to you know and I think I
could've and I should have probably
parallels it with REMS project which was
condensed into a single view which
probably wouldn't have been a very
successful library in fact
now I'm gonna spend when I when I
visited it I will test it for its
canonical quality where is it that you
and I because there's something there no
I I won't understand this I they need to
understand it and I would like to
understand it how can the two of us be
so divided on this and job centrum on
Cornell on the biblioteca top let's just
take those three okay
I think vision shot centrum was a very
very interesting and radical experiment
which has never been followed through on
but except actually in some of the
diagram architecture that that everybody
from REM through say Jima has been
dealing with and testing the idea of a
kind of standardized standard cut
through forms that have if you like a
kind of referential significance and a
plan which in a sense is adapted to
those forms but because it's a generic
plan yeah has no problem being adapted
to those forms and so I just think it's
an experiment I don't think it's
potentially the most successful building
to be built I think it's a very
interesting stress and I think it's way
ahead of you know of present day
experiments in the relationship between
diagrammatic form and generic plans but
it is a for me if you we look at this
together it is a collage image will
collage is this I mean I know you but I
mean this tower key
I mean okay there's something very
strange about this well you actually had
a tower at some out in Ohio somewhere
right and kept the tower yeah right it
was the head of the tail yeah absolutely
it was an extraordinary important it was
a construct yeah and it was read but it
but at least this doesn't have the same
no but it's an enclosed world it's a
small world of stuff you sociologists I
still go to Berlin and I see Mises
National Gallery I see Shiro and see
there next to the you know in the same
area I see shell building and I say to
myself there was something graphic about
the sterling project which inhibits my
capacity yeah I got over that
ya know I get I mean I hate ya I hated
it first yeah I assumed and then I kept
on visiting it and the people loved it
and they people working it and I used it
and I sat in it and I worked in it I
just I thought it was a very elegant
solution to a very difficult problem I
just want you to look at I mean they
can't see this drawing I think this is
it I agree all right yeah but this is
the bibliothèque de France right I've
done I 75 of your New Testament when you
get a chance and I think that the
different things of all is a very good
start at building a library city which
is the which is an assemblage of a
different library unit that he has an
attempt to I can graphically identify
them in particular ways I don't think
it's yet come together you say it's a
two months team you're saying that the
difference between a school work which
is eclectic modernism - I think that
this had he lived well had he won it and
live would have become as powerful as
Meltemi
because I think that's where he was
going and what is it about this that is
what you call contextual modernism what
is the modernism aspect of this it's a
it's a complete yeah what right that's
here so I know I can say this in quoting
it he transforms the the iconic forms of
libraries the two major ones of the blue
a library and the
and the British Museum Library into
contemporary structures the boule
library into a turbine Hall and the and
the you know the Stirling of the British
Library into a into a stress stone I
don't I don't have any problem over here
why do I because you think it's a
cartoon it it has an element of cartoon
in it because it's a two-month project
because it's been resolved as a building
and it hasn't actually got a client
being a competition process what is it
about latina that I don't like I don't
know I think I think it's a very elegant
very elegant resolution of the
vernacular and the and the modern
library now you mentioned the word
vernacular which is one of these two
boards and I would say that one of the
issues that that inhabits sterling after
three is away from the abstract
hard-edged that he was well in the
exhibition I try to demonstrate that his
move away from Corbusier in the 1960s
and the building of the building of
Preston and his photographing of the
British vernacular the functional
tradition layered organically to the
vernacular I think the Brit the modern
vernacular of Leicester of Cambridge and
Florrie there their 19th century
building in humans very fundamental
we'll call them
vernacular than holla but I don't see
let's say they're modern vernacular and
why is it gonna have a problem with the
bibliothèque de France I don't think
that's the vernacular project I said it
was I said it was a library city in
latina latina yes I said latina but it's
lovely shed roof was you know with the
two different pushing through it and
pushing through it yeah
what is what is the problem why don't
you let me tell me well because I think
it's mixed metaphors
I love the drums when they're in Siemens
I love the drums when they are in the
Florence direction right when they stand
alone in their tough form glomer ated
together and Siemens in in a row and
there's four of them in Florence and you
love them when their public space in the
museum right but I'm not sure I like the
way they were arrayed within this room
latina and in fact if you look at the
architecture of latina there is no I
mean
binocular then you have to look at
latina which is is a sort of sort of
reaction teeny and you don't find pitch
ruse and that kind of discourse from the
Roman so I mean to me my both those
projects both the davidic national and
latina are not built and therefore
haven't gone through the iterations that
the built project went through in order
to in other words crystallize and
clarify here I you know I I give like I
am a little bit generous about unbuilt
project because I don't think they I
don't think they have the kind of those
but unless the polemically polemical
project which I don't think that's
engage so let's ask the series of
generic by last remark and that's their
polemical project which I don't think
Serling ever engaged in know right so I
think some architects develop projects
out of analytical position and the
polemical position has a polemical
prototype different in architecture like
the domino house right you and I agreed
that the difference between let's say
Rossi and Sterling was that Rossi wrote
is fundamentally fundamental we we
agreed on that right but if we were
going to define what was happening in
world between 66 let's say and 78 let's
say these two figures would occupy
different positions in the received in
other words although seem to in one
sense define and don't forget all those
architecture moves as well and not very
happily in no it crystallizes into
something that's unmovable yes okay but
if you were going to define them that
moment in time it's more likely that all
there would be a central figure
and Jim unconcerned about the central
moments of the time
don't forget although does the tree and
ally of 73
Jim is a peripheral thing here in that
although participates in several
international writes a book write
several books I would argue that Jim is
not a good marker of the evolution of
things between the 68 and a except in
the schools and I think in the schools
the publication of the black rather than
the 50 to 74 had an exceptional how I
remember it
running through the studios of the
schools the minute it was published it
was on every desk it had the kind of
power that the second volume of course
or compressor Tinley had in Britain
winning well I would like to not a
theoretical power but the ability to to
look at a certain mode of composition a
certain mode
analyzing a program volumetric tree and
recomposing it and I will hand you this
and the unity that Korea's growing and
the black line drawing and the
axonometric and perspectives so I
actually don't think the Korea cave
action metrics a fairly new axle metrics
all along but the perspectives were
important I think that was a very
powerful volume not theoretically but in
in design studio well let me give you
another if you said to me between
certainly you and I were teaching right
during that period yeah Princeton was on
everybody's death no Michael Graves was
on everybody's desk from 68 to 71 life
together you said on everybody says well
I would have thought if you said who was
the hot figure who where that where the
students were I think it was Michael
honestly I really believe mark much more
important and Rossi or sterling or any
other said Michael at the apogee after
Portlandia after Humana after you know
fargo-moorhead any number of projects
when Michael came on to careers
influenced by the way we moved from
Ithaca to Princeton spend eternity
Michaels survey on the my invitation so
I would argue if we said the
movement around 75 I would argue is more
importantly Michael than Spencer I mean
yeah but I do know I don't think well I
think it's early I think we ready for
the me Jim certainly wasn't I mean I see
Jim not as the bellwether of what was I
mean talking about him is a great
architect he said he's one of the five
of that it's not including Michael so
what I'm saying is the the fetish at
that time in all of Charleston is booked
and of course Charles was a chronicler
of post-modernism was Kim was a another
figure hard to categorize I forgive him
what didn't want him play no didn't he
actually was never in any of the
photographs that he photographed not
very interesting he never went and of
course if we take P 3 which is now in 82
he didn't want to play he's the only
so I don't think Jim was concerned there
was an evolution in the work but I don't
think he was concerned by being on
everyone's desk or no it was a neutral
agility he was totally an individualist
and therefore you can't read you can't
read the history of the moment even nor
owners but Rossi built work the real
saturation of work as you see I think
Jim was no but he was extremely central
to a whole range of occupations in
London and without Cedric that would not
have been in my opinion it would not
have been the same Rodgers pasta and
wouldn't have been the same occupation
okay now if we're going to take my 15
years I need to make another one
that in that at that moment it was
Cedric it was Jim and there with John
hey yep all three of them Mavericks all
three of them John never play he
wouldn't touch wouldn't touch it right
and so I think if I were putting
categories between say 68 let's say
between Darby and the decon show another
whole moment the three Mavericks are Jim
Cedric and John which is why they've
probably collected in the CCA with you
know but but you're the interesting
thing is you're you're implying that
architecture the history of architecture
should be the history of of those who
played in a kind of quasi theoretical
quasi what should we say
self-promotional role as opposed to the
history of the building tonight okay
okay okay
certainly could be written by by
maverick but certainly could be I would
never say all the losers oh no yeah yeah
no I didn't mean that I meant when
you've mentioned James who is we're not
talking about you're talking about those
who in a sense were part of a of a group
of people who were in the know or in the
circle or in the public eye and yet
someone like Jim was totally in the
public eye when he died he was one of
the most famous architects in the world
I don't think there's a single well
maybe there are some students today who
could actually name three of this
building there are now there it's an
increasing number one last thing I want
to throw out the word the book because
we've done 15 minutes of our craft last
night and we had open questions I have
to find canonical on one of the Harold
Bloom senses of the word by taking it
from his major book and I define
canonical in
economical building as a cusp work that
is something on the edge that is not
necessarily mainline which has the
capacity to go in any number of
directions like for example I take in
con the Adler and the war houses because
the Avenue war houses come out of the
Trenton bath houses and they can go any
number of ways they go in one direction
into very clearly into the Richards
medical building and in another injuries
more what I would call classical modern
projects okay that's very interesting
because you know the normal use of
canonical which is that if something has
been canonized by you know by its
reception by the public and so on know
you talked about how it is in in physics
how it is in music in fact you gave me
the clue I remember that conversation I
don't know but you know when you've been
doing this for a long time
I know for me Lester is a building that
can move in any number of directions
right it goes quickly at the same time
into Florey and Ambridge but don't
forget when it opens which is close to
67 we the next iteration is start and so
therefore I see Lester at either going
it can go towards glass architecture or
well actually Preston so I mean Lester
actually is a yeah I do
but it goes in to run
born into you know all of any any number
of things so for me that's what defiance
tonight okay
and I make a very strong case for people
that not necessarily fond of but I
believe have produced such works what
would you say in other words I would
argue that any in anyone's career there
are three or four canonical projects no
more Corbeau maybe had five nice maybe
had three or four how many canonical
buildings if you take my definition
would you say they were in June 3 that's
the building which I agree with you
about the disel dog project Roger which
spawns a whole range of things an
efficient shot which was about the form
a whole range of stuff which you may not
like further and I I would have gone
with you with Lester the distal door and
my third we had a corn as a an Emporium
and the book is mouth oh but I think
that was the culmination of what well
because I do something else and went
back to another project by this building
the other that you filthy Olivetti yeah
but would have led to something not
going back to yeah it's going with
another direction I see for the muster
of a comic canonical definition that in
fact that three another canonical yeah
comical definition I see do those three
buildings I'll take notes okay
the the tape just went off and can we
ask for comments no I wouldn't we should
because first of all there are people
okay you that's that you made okay first
of all I think we should thank our two
speakers for a very engaging
conversation
and now we should tell their questions
for either I would say that there's
there's a double thing going on in
Sterling does the the see there's the
associational what he calls the
associational relationship to the whole
tradition of architecture which is
usually for him and a volumetric
relationship as opposed to a stylistic
relationship and then there's the
question of in lighting that he tells
you in this little notebook in the
fifties but his task is to enlarge the
vocabulary of modernist of the modern
movements in modern architecture and
there I think he's extremely interested
his photographs of all the stripey
buildings in the Renaissance is for and
so on so the functional tradition gives
him a kind of volumetric construct and
the the skin tradition of the
Renaissance the surface tradition the
marble tradition of the Renaissance
gives him an ability to play with with
very very thin surfaces and wrappers
which Peter doesn't like but at the same
time are I find sometimes very
excitingly and dialectical relationship
between the volume and the wrapper
between the surface and the volume and
that's a play on that very interesting
moment in the resin architecture right
where we have
the the three great elements of
architecture miss translated in English
as surface plan surface and mass right
as opposed to what Kobe said planned
service and volume right and the only
person who picked up on that was rose
and that was what sterling told me he
got from Rove that volume has a surface
and what he does in his work I think is
to detach sometimes quite playfully and
he's very very deeply involved and
totally agreeing with ro about the whole
question of mannerism and modern
mannerism he likes the play of something
which is almost like a wallpaper wrapped
around the volumetric construct which
goes to the tradition of architecture
and the what and the wallpaper goes to
somewhere else I don't know where it
doesn't you know in rice it goes back to
the campus in envision south
Centrum I have no idea where it's going
strike that what you talking about
there's a question over in the middle
may I put a PS he was asking about the
the movement of the language from one
that was quasi ideological to was it's
certainly an ideological tenor to the
three the Cambridge Oxford and there's
an accommodation antenna to the museum
right so that he was no I think that's
where you move away one what they're
different kinds of programs but I think
there is a there is a sense where yeah I
think there's a sense that the kind of
polemical edge of the of making a modern
vernacular in the
in the red brick in the red building is
in fact transmuted and I think I agree
with Peter 68 and the kind of traumas of
insurrection ISM in every field not just
the actual insurrection ISM but
theoretical interactionism at that
moment I think they're the sort of
quietism of the museums and the
accommodator II sense of moving into a
city and not erasing it but actually
inserting into its fabric right I mean I
think that was already latent I mean
Preston has a kind of you know a long
Electra Jane Jacobs attitude towards the
you know the working-class Street for
example so I think that's always there
but I think there's a lot of there's a
lot of reasons repeated to say there's a
moment from ideology into a kind of
almost kind of pragmatic sense of
adjustments program there were also
issues of Jim's social self and his
relationship when he built in England he
always had a kind of in my view chip on
his shoulder about especially building
if the Oxbridge we can't campus with a
sharpened of the building session may
sharpen the buildings but also explains
them better and of course in Germany he
was a stranger now the context the
context was from the air as opposed to
there's a question in the David
Reinhardt I've got
in the buildings I think for many are
not uniformly disappointing I think so
this first question is do you think
sterling was moving in the direction of
brilliance or irrelevance at that point
and also why don't students know well
they're two reasons one one I don't
think he was moving towards irrelevant
because I think melting and I agree with
Peter it's probably it's like building
Mouse again is a return to what I
consider brilliant so yeah I would call
it I have a whole theory of lateness I
would thought it was Jim which is a
positive thing Nelson is a lake building
a late return to an internal language
that was no longer ideological no longer
of the of the moment but but something
very personal to him it's very important
for people of our generation to insist
on that especially me no but I think the
further question is why don't the
students know about it and of course if
I had given the same quiz to any number
of people students and not students to
name building whether it's sterling or
hungers or whomever there would be this
gap in paths in the history of the past
50 years because all students read about
today our our today's media you know
what's new in the blueprint and mark and
you know any number of journals etc if I
ask the Times critic I'm certain I'm not
convinced he with no three building of
Sterling honestly you know he's coming
up while testing we should test before
you before you take it today
don't think for example when when we
were teaching and I remember with Todd
Williams as a student
everybody had on their desk a nerve
complex okay they also had the black
book at the time of Sterlings okay but
they had books on their desks okay which
of the books that they would have on
their desks today and where are they
they're not that Google yeah the
Wikipedia kids they're any number of
things but they don't have the primary
sources on their desk so I think it's
quite reasonable to think that there's
no demand by their teachers and in any
of the schools for this information so
why should they have it I mean it's not
I I knew that these students wouldn't be
able to do it I teach a course in the
Italian Renaissance
I'll give them about 20 Italian
architects in the course of the semester
at the end of the semester I give them a
quiz named ten Italian architects and
ten of their buildings half the students
we've just finished this semester right
that's all they have to do to pass half
the students fail so bad teaching are
there any questions to follow that is
that's probably why I never give an exam
I just don't want to know
where the rice could have been a bad
building can a building get better over
time and if so can you say that
Sterling's buildings are improving I was
I was once sandy Wilson who was a critic
of bars at Cambridge and I was once very
upset because in a review somebody who
did a really awful team got a much
better Chris and I get my Steam which I
thought was quite good and which he
admitted was quite good with torn apart
and the students we've got an awful
scheme didn't you know just pass through
without a murmur and I asked him
afterwards he said well there are two
kinds of mistakes there are mistakes and
they were interesting mistake and yours
had so many interesting mistakes they
were worth talking about so my sense of
a building like rice which I feel is not
a total success but it's an
extraordinary interesting experiment and
it got built and it's worth talking
about
I don't do battles good I just do it as
a shorthand and IIIi don't think it ever
gets rice gets better some of Jim's
buildings in time get better I don't
think rice from the get-go is it's an
interesting building in any way shape or
form I mean I think it's it was an
opportunity lost it could have been a
better building just I think some of
Michael Graves buildings at Rice were
opportunities lost both of them in my
book very very good architects so I I
believe that if some buildings do age
well I think some buildings don't age
well because there's certainly not taken
care of as well as others and clearly
some of Jim's buildings haven't aged
well we know that Runcorn
a Florrie is not aging well
and but I think what's interesting is
much of this book is about projects that
never got built and I think they are
they do age very well and I think
they're very important as serlio the
architect when he built one building as
ages very well in the books that he did
and the books of Jim this book is going
to help to understand the total ERV of
Jim and the drawings of projects that
never saw the light of day and that's
one of the importance of the of the idea
of the archive to bring a lot of those
buildings which I think will age
extremely well yeah so in the end
instead of not to build for sure I think
if we if we jump ahead it's better to
build but no one to leave no I would if
we jump ahead 50 years Jim's gonna age
very well yes I I think that's a very
good note on which to add this
discussion I think the work that Tony
Wilier
and others have done and actually I
think seeing the student work in the
building in this building further
illuminates the complexity and the
achievement of the teacher in
relationship to a generation or
generations will ensure that Sterling's
reputation will not only endure but
actually grow with the passage of time
and that's what scholarship in a
university should do insofar as it deals
with the history it's just a discipline
so I thank you very much both for this
conversation and for I'm so happy that
Peters class is now going to know three
buildings which by the way when they
meet next Friday they have to be able to
draw as well as know the ante was raised
this morning in case they've forgotten
and I will be there to watch this
spectacle unfold and with that I thank
you all for coming and I wish you would
join us on the second floor in the
exhibition of student
the manual 50 put together of the
students of Sterling a force or a
freshman and continuing conversation
thank you very much